[موسيقى]
في اقاصي شرق الهضبه الاثيوبيه وعلى بعد
نحو 500 كم من العاصمه اديس ابابا نجد
مدينه هرر التاريخيه التي تعود لمملكتها
هرر الاسلاميه والتي استمدت جل ثقافتها من
الممالك الاسلاميه القديمه كنز من التاريخ
يعود لاكثر من الف عام
[موسيقى]
فما الهممنا لدخول مدينه هرر حتى داهمنا
سور المدينه وبواباته الحصينه الخمس حيث
يشهد هذا السور على التاريخ ويسهم في
تشكيل مشهد بديع لملامح الزمان والمكان
غير انه ما زال يكابد المتغيرات ليحتفظ
ببعض ملامحه القديمه
[موسيقى]
فسوروا مدينه هرر بني على طراز معماري
عربي واسلامي مغطيا جهاتها الاربع
لحمايتها من الغزو ويرجع تاريخ السور الى
القرن الثالث عشر الميلادي ولابواب السور
الخمسه مسميات عربيه هي باب النصر وباب
السلام وباب بدر وباب الرحمه وباب البحر
الاحمر ويربط اهل هرر الابواب الخمسه
برمزيه داله على اركان الاسلام الخمس
[موسيقى]
مدينه هرره المسوره هي نتاج حضاره عريقه
في زمن ما قبل الاسلام ونعتز بها كثيرا
وترمز الابواب الخمسه لصور هذه المدينه
لاهم المقومات الاساسيه في الاسلام وهي
اركانه لكن تعود نشاه هذه المدينه بعد
الترابط القوي بين ابناء العمومه لامراء
هرر في منشائهم الاساسي وهي هرل
واتفاقهم لانشاء حكومه في مدينه هرر
الحاليه
هؤلاء هم من اتحدوا واتفقوا على انشاء هذه
المدينه قبل الاسلام
واجدادنا هم اول من قبل الاسلام في شرق
افريقيا
مدينه ذات معالم عربيه واسلاميه متواصله
شهدت حضارات عريقه الا انها نسيت مع مرور
الزمان لكنها ما زالت تحاول ان تحافظ على
معالمها التاريخيه القديمه وتراثها الاصيل
السيد عبد الناصر هو من ابناء هرر واحد
المولعين بتاريخها العريق
جميع الوثائق والمعاملات الرسميه لامراء
هرر كانت تتم باللغه العربيه
وبامكانكم الذهاب الى متحف عبد الله
الشريف لرؤيه هذه الوثائق بحوزه صقوق شراء
اراد تعود لاجداد وقد كتبت باللغه العربيه
ليس هذا فحسب فموقع هرر الجغرافي ايضا
اسهم كثيرا في دخول العادات والثقافات
العربيه الى هرر بالاضافه الى اواصر
الروابط التجاريه بين هرر والجزيره
العربيه
اشهر شارع في هرر هو شارع
يقال انه بني على يد الايطاليين اثناء
احتلالهم هرر وفي نهايه هذا الشارع نجد
دوار فرس مجالا وهو مجسم يمثل بوابات
المدينه
[موسيقى]
ديانات واعراق مختلفه تعايشت في تسامح
لافت هنا في هرر مما جعل اليونسكو تمنحها
لقب مدينه السلام
[موسيقى]
ورغم ان هرر كان محرما على غير المسلمين
دخولها وكل اهلها يدينون بالاسلام الا ان
للكنائس في هرر حضورها الخاص حيث تحتضن
المدينه المسلمين والمسيحيين جنبا الى جنب
ديانات واعراق عده تمازجت وتجانست دون
الغاء لهويه الاخر فالتسامح هنا في هرر في
اسماء اياته
[موسيقى]
اول ما يلفت الانتباه في تفاصيل هذه
المدينه هي ازقتها الضيقه والبيوت القديمه
الاصيله المشرعه ابوابها وكانها ترحب
بالزائر دون ترقباب
[موسيقى]
تزهو هرر بالالوان فالوان جدران المدينه
وزخرفتها ومنازلها القديمه تنبئ عن حب
الحياه وفي الوقت نفسه فيها شجن وارتباط
بالماضي يابى سكان هذه المدينه ان ينمحي
او ينسى مدينه لها في التاريخ وسام ولكن
على وشك النسيان
[موسيقى]
رغم انه هرر فيها حضاره وتاريخ عميق يعني
كبير الى انه هذه يعني ابتداء حتى من نفسي
انا يعني احس انه صح انا اتيت الى العاصمه
بحثا عن الرزق للحصول على فرص افضل لكن
هناك نتائج سلبيه لهذا القرار يعني ممكن
تحدث فجوه فجوه يعني حضريه انا ما اعرف
اشياء كثيره الان عن بلدي عن هرر عن
تاريخها وممكن حتى عيالي انا ما اقدر انقل
لهم التاريخ كما موجود في الجيل السابع
لذلك يعني انا افضل مثلا لو
الجهات الحكوميه في عرب في اقليم عرب او
حتى رجال الاعمال في هارب وخارج هرب انه
يكون هناك يدعم ويحفزه الشاب انه ما يطلع
لكي لا تندثر هذا لا يندثر هذا التاريخ
وخلال جولتنا في هرر التقينا بعبد الحفيظ
عبدوش وهو احد احفاد الامير عبد الله اخر
امير لهرر تجولنا معه داخل بيت اسلافه
وحكى لنا اساطير اجداده وحضاراتهم التي
سادت وامتدت حكما وحكمه
دوله
اسلاميه في الشرق الافريقيا اذا اعلنه
الهرريون القدامى كانوا هم اول من استقبل
الاسلام في سنواته الاولى وبعد ذلك
وبالتحديد في عام 405 هجريا في يوم
عاشوراء من شهر محرم اجتمع علماء هرر
واعلنوا ان هرر هي عاصمه سلطنه عدل
المقامه في شرق افريقيا امتدادا من زليع
الى مدينه مصوع وضمت تحتها قبائل الصومال
والعفر واجزاء من المناطق الساحليه على
البحر الاحمر وكانت بذلك اول مملكه
اسلاميه في شرق افريقيا اقيمت بطريقه
سلميه ومن غير حرب
ظلت هرر على مدى تاريخها مركز شعاع علمي
وثقافي مميز فضمت داخل اسوارها 99 مسجدا
وزاويه تتلمذ فيها عدد كبير من رجال العلم
الذين درسوا في مختلف مجالات المعرفه
عندما يقال ان في هذا دحر العلم او انتهى
فتره العلماء كان يوجد في مدينه هارك اكثر
من 600 مفتي 600 رجل وامراه الافتاء لم
يكن محصورا على على الرجال فحسب ولكن كان
هنالك اكثر من 600 رجل وامراه يتميزون
بالعلم الشرعي وخاصه في المذهب الشافعي
بالمذاهب الاخرى ايضا
الناظر الى هرر بعين الغريب عن المنطقه
فانه من السهل التنبؤ بوجود حضاره اسلاميه
تعود الى الازمان الغابره ولكن اذا نظرنا
اليها بعين ساكنيها سنرى انها رابع اقدس
مدينه اسلاميه في العالم
وانها مدينه العلم والعلماء وانها نافست
لعقود حواضر علميه اسلاميه كبيره لكنها
اليوم شبه منسيه
النهر يعلم انه يا علماء هناك دلائل عديده
على ان هرر هي مدينه العلم والعلماء قديما
كان هناك العديد من حلقات العلم وتدريس
القران داخل اسوار هذه المدينه الصغيره
واول ما يقوم به جميع اطفال هذه المدينه
صباحا هو تعلم القران
ويقومون بذلك طوال اليوم
حتى ان هرر في فتره من الفترات كانت تسمى
مدينه القران او الحفاظ
يا قران
[موسيقى]
من هذا الماضي المجيد ورثه المدينه كنزا
استثنائيا وهو مسجد جمعه الذي يعود تاريخه
الى القرن العاشر الميلادي اقدم جامع ليس
في هرر فقط بل في عموم شرق افريقيا حافظ
الهرريون على تقاليد المسجد المتوارثه فلم
يتغير شكله المعماري الاساسي رغم الترميم
والتحديث
خلف مسجد جمعه فصل لقصه هذه المدينه من
مجد وتاريخ عريق حضاره تحدت الزمن واسهمت
في انتشار الاسلام على يد امرائها ليس في
اثيوبيا فحسب بل في شرق افريقيا وكانت مقر
حكم وسياده روى لنا تفاصيلها احد احفاد
الامير نور مجاهد
جهود اجدادنا كانت احد اهم عوامل لانتشار
الدين الاسلامي ليس في منطقه هرر واثيوبيا
فحسب بل في جل مناطق الشرقيه القاره
الافريقيه
وما سهل عليهم ذلك انهم كانوا يناصرون
اصحاب الحق ايا كان دينه وعرقه
وكانوا يؤمنون بالمساواه واعاده الحقوق
الى اصحابها والتاريخ يشهد على وقوف
الهرريين مع الصومال في القرن الماضي
فالهرريون لا يعملون لدنياهم وينسون
اخرتهم هذا ما ورثناه من اجدادنا ونورثه
نحن للاجيال القادمه وما نزرعه في ابنائنا
واحفادنا حتى تصبح نصره المظلوم عاده لدى
اجيال هرر القادمه
[موسيقى]
هذه المدينه العريقه التي انشات في القرن
السابع الميلادي والتي استمدت جل ثقافتها
من الممالك الاسلاميه القديمه يرى الزائر
في الوهله الاولى ان هناك حلقه وصل غريبه
بينها وبين الثقافه العربيه والاسلاميه
على عمرانها وهوياتها بسبب تعاقب ممالك
اسلاميه وعربيه عده
فالبيت الهرري يشكل الجزء الاكثر خصوصيه
في هذه المدينه
فتصاميم منازل هرر خارجيا وداخليا تخضع
للعادات المستمده من الدين الاسلامي بينما
تمزج صفاتها المعماريه بين الثقافه
العربيه والبيئه المحليه ولكل عنصر هنا
اهميته الرمزيه والعمليه
عماره البيوت الهراريه مستمده من الدين
الاسلامي وجميع الادوات المعلقه هنا على
الجدران لها دلالات اجتماعيه ويتم
استخدامها في مختلف المناسبات مثل الاعراس
والعزاء وغيرهما ولكل عنصر هنا اهميته
الرسميه والعمليه
غير بعيد من هنا زرنا سوق هرر الشعبي
فاسواق المدينه لا يلجا سكانها للتبضع
فحسب بل كل حسب حاجته فهذا ساع للرزق وهذا
مستريح بعد عناء طويل وغيرهم الناس هنا
وسطاء يفصلون احلامهم لمستقبل واعد
كتراثهم الغني فالكل ياخذ حاجته من السوق
حسب رغبته
ومن اشهر الاسواق هنا سوق القات حيث تشتهر
المدينه بهذه النبته ورغم ان القات في
بلدان اخرى يجرم متعاطيه لكن القات هنا في
هرر يعد سلعه استراتيجيه تمثل احدى دعامات
الاقتصاد الاثيوبي وهو رفيق جلساتهم
وتزدهر اسواق القات قبيل الظهيره الى غروب
الشمس وهي فتره تناوله من قبل سكان
المدينه
التعايش والتالف من سمات البشر ولكن هنا
في هرر هناك تعايش من نوع اخر وهو التعايش
مع الطيور الجارحه فالصقور هنا لا تشكل
خطرا على الاهالي بل هي مصدر رزق وجلب
للسياح
ازقه هرر الضيق لم تطرها مشروعات الاعمار
بقيت صامده في وجه التمدن والعولمه ومن
بين ازقه هرر نجد زقاق المصالحه او زقاق
السلام كما يطلق عليه سكان هرر فهذا
الزقاق الضيق لا يسمح للاشخاص ان يمروا
فيه دون ان يسلموا على بعضهم بعضا ويدعو
سكان هرار الاشخاص المتخاصمين للمرور في
هذا الزقاق لكي يتصالحوا
متحف عبد الله الشريف من اهم معالم هرر
وخلال جولتنا زرنا المتحف الخاص للسيد عبد
الله الذي حول بيته لتحفه فنيه جمع فيها
العديد من المخطوطات العربيه القديمه
وعملات معدنيه ومقتنيات تراثيه تحط رحالها
في الماضي
هذا هو متحف الشريف الخاص وانا من قمت
بتاسيسه وقمت بجمع العديد من المقتنيات
الاثريه وفي هذا المتحف يوجد العديد من
المخطوطات يعود تاريخها الى 1300 عام وما
ترونه هنا هو مجرد عينات لما يوجد لدينا
من المخطوطات ودعوني اخذكم الى غرفه
التخزين السريه لديه والتي يوجد فيها
العديد من المخطوطات القيمه والنادره
هنا توجد المجموعه الرئيسيه من المخطوطات
التي نحتفظ بها في هذا المتحف وتوجد هنا
كتب في مختلف المجالات العلميه مثل علوم
القران والحديث وعلوم النحو بالاضافه الى
الطب والرياضيات وغيرها وما نقوم به ليس
تجميع المخطوطات فحسب بل نقوم بصيانتها
واعاده عمل الغطاء للكتب من الجلد
ولا المغترمه
ماذا بك يا رب هذا نلطف منك لا يشملني
زائر مدينه هررت تفاجئه انها ليلا تلبس
حله جديده تعبر في كل تفاصيلها عن تنوعها
اذ تعلو في احد البيوت ابتهالات ومدح
للنبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
لاجلها فالتصوف متجذر في نفوس ساكنيها
وابنيتها وكل ما تراه من حولك
عفوا
نتمنى ان نكون من المتصوفين كما كان
اسلافنا من قبل هنا في هارون فالتصوف ليس
طريقه دينيه وحسب لدى الهرويين بل هو
اسلوب للحياه اباؤنا علمونا ان نلتزم
بجميع الاداب مثلا نحن حتى اليوم وان كبرت
اعمارنا نستجيب للاوامر بنظرات من شيوخنا
ونشتغل في جميع اوقاتنا بالذكر خاصه في
وقت ما بين المغرب والعشاء الجميع هنا
مهتم بقراءه وحفظ القران الكريم والذكر
والاوراد اليوميه خاصه الصلاه على النبي
مع الاسره فالارتباط بالتصوف اصبح من
العادات في هرر ولكن في السنوات الاخيره
هناك بعض العوامل الدخيله والعولمه التي
اثرت على المجتمع الهرر
الى
مفتيات زناره زمن النار
[موسيقى]
وفي ناحيه اخرى من هذه المدينه يستقبل
اهالي وسكان هرار صديق المساء انها الضباع
تقطن هذه الضباع في الغابات والمزارع
المجاوره للمدينه فعلاقه سكان هرر بالضباع
تعود لاكثر من قرنين من الزمان حيث يذكر
سكان المدينه ان جفافا وقحطا قد حل مما
جعل الضباعه تهاجم السكان والماشيه فقرر
السكان توكيل شخص من بينهم يقوم باعطاء
الضباع ما بقي من طعامهم لتعقد هدنه
وصداقه بين الضباع وسكان هرر حتى يومنا
هذا
عمل به عمل الجيوب ورثت هذه المهنه من
والدي الذي قام باطعام هذه الضباع لاكثر
من اربعين سنه وانا منذ صغري اساعد والدي
في اطعامها مما جعلني اتمكن من التمييز
بينهم حسب اختلاف درجه الوانهم وعلى حسب
طبائعهم فهنالك من يستجيب للاوامر وهنالك
من يتطفل على طعام غيره
العام السيوف من ادابز
[موسيقى]
عادات اهل هرر لم تتغير كثيرا بفعل الزمان
وتقلباته خاصه في زيجاتهم حيث سمحت لنا
الفرصه لمشاركه فرحه تاسيس بيت جديد
فالايقاعات والاهازيج تناهت الى مسامعنا
كانها رجع صدى لعرس اجداد قديم فهذا غيض
من فيض حضارتهار التي هي على وشك النسيان
[موسيقى]